GOALS OF A GLOBAL WEALTH TAX AND
PERHAPS PERHAPS AN INTERNATIONAL
GREEN NEW DEAL.
IF THE PRESS WERE DOING ITS JOB,
YOU’D HEAR A LOT ABOUT THE
BLOOMBERG NEW ECONOMY FORUM
WHICH HAS BEEN GOING ON ALL
WEEK.
ATTENDED BY MODERN DAY GLOBAL
LEADERS AND WEALTHY ELITES THAT
SUPPORTED JOE BIDEN.
THEY’RE SO CONFIDENT IN THEIR
AGENDA, SO BUOYED BY THE
AMERICAN FIRST MOVEMENT AND
THEIR DEFEAT THAT THEY’RE NOT
TRYING TO HIDE THEIR DISDAIN FOR
AMERICAN SOVEREIGNTY.
>> WERE YOU SURPRISED HOW BADLY
AMERICA HAS DONE ON THAT?
>> OH, IT’S MIND-BLOWING.
>> WHEN THE PARIS AGREEMENT CAME
INTO FORCE, THE UNITED STATES
WITH DREW FROM IT AND LEFT US
AND THE OTHER COUNTRIES AROUND
THE WORLD DISAPPOINTED.
>> THE MARKETPLACE IS ENCOURAGED
BY HAVING A LEADER NOW THAT IS
MORE INCLUSIVE.
>> INCLUSIVE.
OF COURSE, IF THEY HAVE THEIR
WAY, YOU’RE GOING TO HAVE NO SAY
IN THE FUTURE OF THE GLOBAL
ECONOMY.
NO WAY TO AFFECTS IT, NO WAY TO
CHANGE IT.
IT’S UP TO AMERICAN PATRIOTS TO
OPPOSE WHAT THEY’RE TRYING TO DO
AT ALMOST EVERY TURN.
THAT MEANS SUPPORTING SENATORS
KELLY LOEFFLER AND DAVID PURDUE
IN GEORGIA IN THE RUN-OFF ON
JANUARY 5.
IT MEANS KEEPING PRESSURE ON
REPUBLICAN ELECTED OFFICIALS
ACROSS THE BOARD.
LET’S FACE IT, BEFORE TRUMP, A
LOT OF THEM WERE WRONG ON BOTH
TRADE AND IMMIGRATION.
HAVE TO KEEP AN EYE ON THEM.
OVER THE NEXT FOUR YEARS, THESE
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO COME
UNDER ENORMOUS MEDIA AND
FINANCIAL PRESSURE TO APPEASE
THE GLOBAL ELITES.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THE GLOBALISTS
ARE DETERMINED TO RAM THROUGH
THEIR AGENDA.
GIVEN BIDEN’S AGE AND MENTAL
ACUITY, THEY FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE
A VERY NARROW WINDOW, SHORT
WINDOW TO ACHIEVE THEIR GRAND
DESIGN.
IF BIDEN GETS INTO OFFICE, GET
READY FOR THE FIGHT OF YOUR LIFE
OVER THE NEXT YEAR.
AT EVERY TURN, THEY WILL TRY TO
SUBVERT YOUR RIGHTS AND TAKE
YOUR PROSPERITY.
TO START, THEY’LL CRATER YOUR
PERSONAL FINANCES WITH INSANE
CLIMATE POLICIES.
>> NEED A ECONOMY TRANSITION
BACKING THOSE THAT ARE PART OF
THE SOLUTION AND TAKING CAPITOL
AWAY FROM THOSE THAT ARE PART OF
THE PROBLEM.
>> CAP AND TRADE MECHANISM OR
CARBON TAX.
>> AN ACTIVE CARBON MARKET WITH
A CARBON PRICE THAT WOULD
CONTINUE TO STEP UP AROUND LEVEL
EVERY YEAR.
>> GUARANTEED TAX INCREASES ON
ENERGY WOULD DEVASTATE THE
MIDDLE CLASS.
THEY KNOW THAT.
THE ELITES KNOW THAT.
THAT’S THEIR POINT, REMEMBER?
WE MADE A POINT TO GET TO AOC TO
STOP THESE DEALS.
BUT BLOOMBERG AND HIS PALS ARE
SMART.
THEY KNOW EXACTLY THE KIND OF
RHETORIC THAT IS NEEDED TO WIN
PEOPLE LIKE ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ OVER.
>> CLIMATE CHANGE WILL KILL US
ALL.
IF WE’RE WAITING FOR THINGS TO
BE DELIVERED IN 2050, WE WON’T
BE AROUND TO SEE THEM.
>> WE DON’T HAVE A LOT OF TIME,
WHEN 10 AND 20 YEARS.
>> WE DON’T HAVE 10 OR 12 YEARS
FOR NEW POWER STATIONS.
WE NEED THEM IN 18 MONTHS.
>> Laura: ON TRADE, BLOOMBERG
AND HIS GLOBALIST CRONIES MADE
CLEAR IN A SPECIAL REPORT WHAT
THEIR OVERRIDING GOAL IS.
STICKING TOGETHER BY GUARDING
AGAINST THE RISK OF THE U.S. AND
CHINA DECOUPLING.
THEY DON’T WANT THAT.
BLOOMBERG AND LOTS OF OTHER
AMERICANS HAVE BILLIONS TIED UP
IN CHINA.
SO DECOUPLING FROM THE COMMUNIST
REGIME WOULD BE A DISASTER EVEN
THOUGH IT WOULD BE A HUGE BOON
TO AMERICAN INDUSTRIES AND
WORKERS.
ON COVID, BILLIONAIRES LIKE BILL
GATES COULD BARELY HIDE THEIR
EXCITEMENT FOR WHAT A BIDEN
PRESIDENCY WILL BRING.
>> AS PEOPLE COME IN, DO THEY
HAVE A DIGITAL CERTIFICATE THAT
SAYS WHETHER THEY HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED OR NOT.
THE U.S. REJOINS THE WHO, THIS
IDEA OF WHAT IS THE VACCINE
CERTIFICATE LOOKS LIKE,
HOPEFULLY THAT DIALOGUE WILL
BEGIN.
>> Laura: SHOW ME YOUR PAPERS.
DON’T FOR A SECOND THINK THAT
YOU’LL HAVE A SEAT AT THAT TABLE
FOR THIS DIALOGUE.
YOU’RE JUST SUPPOSED TO SIT DOWN
AND DO WHAT YOU’RE TOLD,
REMEMBER?
THAT’S WHAT DR. FAUCI TOLD US
ANYWAY.
THE CHINESE CDC’S CHIEF
EPIDEMIOLOGIST HAD BASICALLY THE
SAME MESSAGE YESTERDAY.
>> WE HAVE A COMMUNITY VALUE, A
HIGH INDIVIDUAL VALUE, IN THE
UNITED STATES AND EUROPEAN
COUNTRIES.
PERSONAL RIGHT.
IT’S A TOP PRIORITY.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, EVERYBODY
TAKES THE ORDER AND FOLLOW THE
INSTRUCTION.
>> Laura: EVERYONE TAKES THE
ORDER AND FOLLOWS THE
INSTRUCTION OR ELSE.
DO WHAT YOU’RE TOLD.
MASK UP, OPEN YOUR WALLET,
DISTANCE.
GET THE VACCINE CERTIFICATE.
GIVE UP YOUR FREEDOM, YOUR
AUTONOMY.
DO NOT UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCES
ASK ANY REAL QUESTIONS.
DOESN’T THAT SOUND LIKE A FUN
WORLD TO LIVE IN?
THIS IS THE TYPE OF MENTALITY
THAT WILL GUIDE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION’S COVID RESPONSE.
GOOD OLD JOE WILL BEND OVER
BACKWARDS TO APPEASE THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
A PROSPECT THAT HAS EMBOLDENED
THE HEAD DOCTOR.
>> THE FASTEST WAY OUT OF THIS
PANDEMIC IS FOR US TO WORK
TOGETHER IN SOLIDARITY ACROSS
SECTORS AND BORDERS.
VACCINATION WILL PROLONG THE
PANDEMIC.
THE PANDEMIC HAS TAKEN SO MUCH
FROM US.
BUT IT HAS ALSO GIVEN US
SOMETHING, THE OPPORTUNITY TO
THINK AFRESH ABOUT THE WORLD
THAT WE WANT.
WE CAN BUILD THE HEALTHIER,
SAFER AND FAIRER WORLD THAT WE
ALL WANT AND BUILD BACK BETTER.
>> Laura: THERE IT IS.
YOU THINK IT’S ANY COINCIDENCE
THAT HE’S BORROWING BIDEN’S
CAMPAIGN SLOGAN OR WHO IS
BORROWING FROM WHOM THESE DAYS?
IT’S A SIGNAL THEY’RE ALL ON THE
SAME TIME, ALL HAVE THE SAME END
GOAL.
INDIVIDUALISM AND INDIVIDUAL
RIGHTS WILL BE SUBVERTED TO THE
GLOBAL RIGHTS, THE COMMUNAL
RIGHTS.
IT’S A SIGN THAT JOE BIDEN WON’T
PUT AMERICA FIRST.
HE’S NOT OUT TO MAKE AMERICA
BETTER AND HE WON’T MAKE THAT
HIS FIRST PRIORITY.
HE’S GOT TO DO THE BIDDING OF
BLOOMBERG, WALL STREET, BIG
BUSINESS AND THE REST OF THE
SPECIAL INTERESTS THAT BANK
ROLLED HIS CAMPAIGN.
OF COURSE, THAT MEANS KOWTOWING
TO THE ELITES THAT DON’T GIVE A
DAMN ABOUT JOBS AND WAGES FOR
AMERICANS.
THEY NEVER DID.
IT’S IMPERATIVE THAT WE HOLD THE
SENATE NEXT YEAR.
WITH THE MAJORITY, WE HAVE A
CHANCE AT THWARTING THIS KIND OF
TAKEOVER, THE LEVERS OF POWER
FROM OUR GOVERNMENT TO A
GOVERNMENT FAR, FAR AWAY.
WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT THE
AMERICA FIRST MOVEMENT CONTINUES
TO DELIVER RESULTS THAT OUR IT
IS SETS AND WE CAN USE TO BUILD
A FUTURE WHERE OUR CHILDREN CAN
THRIVE UNDER THE SYSTEM OF